à trois jours de la rentrée scolaire le
ministre de l'éducation jean pierre
chevènement présentait les grandes
lignes de cette rentrée au cours d'une
conférence de presse pour monsieur
chevénement la réussite de la
modernisation est une affaire de survie
à laquelle l'éducation nationale est
appelée à jouer un rôle essentiel
les ministres a par ailleurs déterminé
quatre grandes priorités qui devraient
guider son action
ce sont la formation des maîtres
l'enseignement technique la formation
permanente et l'école élémentaire
avec déjà des nouveautés pour la rentrée
ce soir par exemple ce sont les
transports scolaires ou encore l'effort
qui sera mise sur la formation technique
dans les lycées outre nous